[Music]
deer creek international business
solutions how can i help you i am ready
well that's great ladybug ladybug your
new operational name oh i see what
you're doing ladybug's supposed to be
lucky
you don't have bad luck
really
my bad luck is biblical i'm not even
trying to kill people when someone dies
remember the suicidal bell boy you drove
him to the hospital hang in there
buddy die okay the wedding tequila
johannesburg
it's time for some change you want it
simple for your first job back it
doesn't get simpler
we need to find the person who took that
case
that's too easy
[ __ ] what remember those two wackos from
the bolivia jobs the twins yeah not so
sure they're twins get off the train
i missed my stop something else going on
here hi
you don't remember me you look like
every white homeless man i've ever seen
really you don't remember me
oops he's a pack of dicks lady i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm i'm working on it
get off at the next stop sounds so easy
when you say it one little prick from
this you know what happens yes your
blood congeals
i said
want to yes the whole story what's
waiting for us in kyoto the white death
with his army of assassins there's this
soulless psychotic leader with the
largest criminal organization on the
planet shoved right inside
i don't see the white death letting any
of us off this train
we need to come up with a plan
[Music]
what's happening to your face maybe
there was a little head trauma
[Music]
i i got to get off this train
[Music]
sorry buddy
exclusively in movie theaters a really
good puss
you don't have to be nervous i i'm not
nervous
well they're all so impressive you're
impressive they're gonna be obsessed
with you
i just wanna feel good they're not as
nihilistic as they look on the internet
you guys this is me oh
whoa
this is your first relationship oh no
you just kind of give that vibe
oh you know that has weed in it right
[Applause]
[Music]
who wants to play body spotty spotties
so how do you play
if you draw the piece of paper that has
the x on it you are the murderer let's
go
and if you're the murderer you have to
kill someone by touching them on the
back
the most important part if you come
across a body you have to yell
[Music]
is that the lights
david
our friend is dead
someone's doing this they're trying to
kill us off one by one that would be so
obvious if i were the killer in the
window for the
[Applause]
i'm staying safe really because it looks
like you're grabbing a meat cleaver to
go look for my boyfriend
[Applause]
you should watch a girl
[Music]
i brought something what is it
it's zucchini bread
yum
girl pop girl
[Music]
joseph are you coming for easter i don't
know mom i'm really busy i just tested
for this pilot you're going to be a
pilot a network pilot for like a tv show
ah you're playing a pilot on the tv show
no a lawyer
you could have been a lawyer if you only
applied yourself
a little father and son road trip it's
gonna be fun easter sunday is like the
filipino super bowl there he is there's
mike
welcome home bro see you tonight okay i
just got here you got to follow your
dream and become a beer spokesman that
was my dream let's get the party started
baby and i got to follow mom's stream
and become a nurse
joe vanessa yeah joe valencia you're
still driving that same raggedy ass car
what what happened you just gave up huh
and it's your dad you know me and him
used to be real intimate back in the day
oh really yeah i could have been your
mama
but clearly i'm not yeah i've literally
never seen this many filipinos in the
same place before
we're sending gifts to our family in the
philippines i'm sending this brand new
hairdryer if it makes your hair look
like that i wouldn't send it how dare
you how dare you we should put them both
in the box and ship it
my mom is at war with my tita theresa
and they don't even know why did you
really have to wear the same dress as my
mom oh i can't help it if i wear it
better this is war oops
family is a mess we're counting on you
to fix it bye
ladies and
gentlemen we're all we got so let's get
the party started baby
moments like these are few and far
between let's enjoy it do not find
out families fight a lot make sure
you're not late for dinner but we love a
lot too
your cousin eugene owes me a lot of
money
can you lend it to me no
does he have a death wish deluxe is
legit crazy i once saw him shoot
somebody in a dick what right in the
actual hole in the hole
here we go
where is my money here are my atm cards
my pin number is 12 17. oh also is mine
why do you all have the same pin number
no right the guy who couldn't beat
mayweather
nessa can we go get coffee you can go
ahead and email me pretty much the same
just take the aol off that [ __ ] nessa
at
daleycity.com got it
[Music]
every step you take
you're moving forward a moment in time
but what if for every step you take
backwards
he moves backwards in time
[Music]
i'm 11.
a number that looks like two people
standing next to each other this is our
last weekend before middle school i want
to go backwards not forward
when is the person you used to be
and the other one
is the person you're becoming let's go
back like two months
then we can have somewhere all over
again
and the older i am
the more complicated my life gets
that can't be real
of course it's real
he's dead
we make a pact
to try and find out who he was
this is on us
[Music]
daisy say something to you you can't not
look for someone who's gone
someone is waiting for this guy to come
home
[Music]
those are some tough years
it can be so hard to know what's right
you'll make it through
[Music]
you remember when they used to be better
to be older
it doesn't seem all that great
i don't want this weekend to end
[Music]
i don't want us to end
you'll never find another who will love
you like me you'll never find another
so if you had some money what would you
do
i just want to be able to experience
things
[Music]
i just want to be free
hi
i paid 400 and it was never applied to
my balance
sorry how much uh interest is being
added a month
how are you
i need a real job just to like pay my
loans emily yo
let me hook you up
in the next hour you will make 200 cash
but you will have to do something
illegal
you won't be in danger but you will be
breaking the law yo you gonna pay for
that
sorry
i said are you gonna pay for that
oh my god
sorry man
tomorrow you have the option to do
another job okay what do i have to do
you make that much selling tvs
sometimes tvs sometimes
other things you can show me how to do
it
none of this is safe
but if you listen to exactly what they
say you'll be fine hello yeah it's still
available one second
you're scared of me
yes
hey
get out of the car
we're serious people
you should be scared of us
you told me it was a one-time team with
him i want my cut i just lost everything
people just keep taking from you until
you make the goddamn rules yourself
you know what my mistake really was
i didn't go far enough
[Music]
you can't be here it's me
i'm serious okay one more move and you
get an eye full of pepper it's me
i grew up always feeling like i was an
older woman trapped in the body of a
little girl i wrote a book if you're not
getting paid for something it's a hobby
and hobbies are disgusting and i did my
darndest to keep my inner old gal to
myself yeah we bruh lee yes we
get together i thought it would be super
fun if we all lie down and did a past
life regression what you should go do it
we'll just meet back up at the house
welcome lay down moonshine and think
about who you want to be
i'm a 70 year old woman trapped in the
body of a 30 year old who just needs a
minute to rest
[Music]
so you were thinking about old lady
stuff and he turned into one so he
should be able to turn you back into you
where did he go
we're never going to find him
coming coming are you sick you sound
weird
buddy well hello i'm max aunt rita i'm
jack i take care of cheese when max out
of town
this is max ontearita how often do you
ladies meet for your wine club every day
sometimes we spend the weekend
how are we supposed to grow old on the
french riviera if you're 50 years out of
me you are scheduled to cover the
pilates event post pictures people see
you at a party they think you're fun
and let's reset
you know these pocket computer photo
albums are my job these days i get paid
to post pictures
wow looking good aunt rita
everything that's happening for you
right now
is because you're showing the world who
you are we're getting some interesting
offers for rita
post more of my glammy grammy people are
dying for her reader you got a man well
this guy's young he's young matt you
didn't want to be old what you wanted
was to be you luca i laid down in that
pod and when i came out i was in this
body okay you're coming in with a lot of
energy
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
a horrible thing happened to you
i just want you to be able to move on
with your life
come here
it's coming up on a year
i have something that's planned and i
need a partner in crime the b67 tv tower
i haven't climbed since becky if you
don't confront your fears you are always
going to be afraid
[Music]
let's do it
let's climb your stupid tower
[Applause]
[Music]
i was really ripped you're awesome that
is the becky that we need for this trip
this is sick
damn it hunter what are you getting us
into
okay so just stay behind me one wrong at
a time
[Music]
see
it's easy
you're doing great
becky you gotta come up here
[Music]
hey trust me
what was that
[Music]
[Music]
hunter how do we get down
i don't have a signal
our water is down there in that bag we
have 50 feet of rope
i think i could drop myself lower
okay i'm going to jump onto the fabric
every hour that passes the weaker we get
if anyone called 9-1-1 they'd be here by
now
what is it that dan used to say if
you're scared of dying don't be afraid
to let
[Music]
tuscan growth has a program and they
take all the top managers to italy
amber pack your bags
what you're going to italy
i have a feeling you're going to fall in
love okay i was kind of thinking that
too
benvenuta
ciao
welcome everyone i would like to
introduce our ceo
nick martucci ciao i meet you
he's my assistant cat
i'm excited to get to know you a little
better
[Music]
what roles do love and affection play in
your life where is this going
i'm really happy you're here amber
i can't afford this it's next week
[Music]
i'm a repository for mickey's dirty
secrets
you seem so open-minded
why does everyone keep telling me that
[Music]
listen i think something weird might be
going on
look guys
nick's in the study working what is this
clue he's killing colonel mustard with
the lead pipe
[Music]
[Music]
this program sucks
lighten up a little bit please
[Music]
hey look out the window
welcome to my party
[Music]
thank guys so much for having us this is
my chance to reconnect with the girls
did mom shoot someone's face this little
bump right here that's you
i still miss her every day
what's that there's something crossing
up ahead
keep the girls in the car stay in the
car okay just stay in the car what
happened yeah
okay what's he saying
i've never seen anything like this
multiple attacks
without eating its prey
lies don't do that
at least no lion i've ever seen
[Music]
go back to the calls
oh breathe slow down
we're in his territory now
it's the law of the jungle
it's the only law that matters
to they've got guns you shouldn't be out
here what are you doing
i've got to get my girls out of here
i need you to trust me right now
i'm coming back
don't you move
okay
if you're gonna do this
do it right
chart everything out stick with the plan
i don't take any stupid risks people die
every day at sea
we're almost there a couple more days
why don't we take one day off just relax
i'm sure don't stop on the islands of
despair you go past to paradise the
island the boat of despair for me
[Music]
on a boat there's one captain told me
you establish yourself to leave go away
right now she thinks she's got to be
wrapped around a little finger
maybe if you weren't jealous you
wouldn't be saying that kind of stuff
about myself it's got nothing to do with
me whatever magic you think you're gonna
get better go talk about my wife i'll
talk about her in the game way i want to
[Music]
this woman
[Music]
she's bringing him down
[Music]
she's got you so twisted up
go away you know how dangerous this is i
don't want you to come here no
she's got to go
people die every day at sea
[Music]
it was always just my mom and me
to have a family that's what i really
want
no way i got a cousin that is the
whitest man i've ever seen he wants to
meet up
oliver cousin evie it sounds so jane
austen when you say it like that
you know my mom always wanted to take me
to england to learn about our family
history there's a wedding coming up
actually you should come i would love to
but come on everyone is dying to meet
you
wow it's incredible
i believe this is one of our important
guests evie this is a close friend of
the family walter deville uh hi hi
looking forward to getting to know you
better
[Music]
what are you doing down there
miss you should return to your room
we're all so delighted that you're here
which ones have the groom the groom and
his brides will make their grand
entrance tomorrow
ready
i can't shake the feeling that everyone
is staring at me
you and walter seem to be getting off
the clothes evie
i'm curious though what have you told
you
about us
ow
let me see
there she is where are the bride and
groom
as you all know there has been someone
missing from this table
but that once broken bond will be
renewed tonight
to even
my new bride
i want to go home but this is your home
help me
dear hello please
hawker here there's a young lady who
seems quite distressed
i'm so glad you've come to your senses
[Music]
leave
right now
the guy in the gray hoodie is robbing
the bank who's in charge here well she
is but we're both i'm and i'm the
manager
estelle valerie
still um once they leave you lock the
front of back doors you understand me
you lock them all
got the fbi the gbi
everybody here
[Music]
i'm sorry okay this is sergeant bernard
is everyone all right in there as long
as everybody stays calm nobody gets hurt
i have a bomb and i'm gonna kill myself
and everybody in here my commands and
i'm there
hey there this the windy hills wells
fargo
uh
yes ma'am this is the wells fargo
uh yeah i need to talk to bridget about
my 401k i think she made a nine thousand
dollar mistake sorry hear that man can i
take a message for you
when fraud was committed the va's don't
want disability check from me
i've had some problems with veteran
affairs myself how about you release one
of those ladies no
i need everybody to see what's happening
here i need to fire trucks i need the
news cameras you have my undivided
attention
standing there
i don't want the banks calling all the
people here
i'm gonna work this out brother brother
i do not have as much time as you think
i do
snipers are in place coming through come
and do it
get the blondes get the lights
[Music]
what do i need to do to get the
attention that i need right now
everything you say everything you do
it matters
you matter
[Music]
all you got to do now is just make good
brian
[Music]
just make good
you ever been robbed before once
[Music]
wait up wait up
what do you do with all this junk
it keeps me busy
another long night of crime and violence
some say it's only a matter of time
before the city implodes
i think we're finished here come on beat
it
i found him
samaritan
samaritan died 25 years ago
that's what they say
you think you live across from a
superhero do you have a therapist kid
good
samaritan's dead
i pick up garbage for a living foul
smeared and cleaned up the streets
you mind your business on my mind i
don't believe you
are you okay
oh cool
how strong are you
kind of struggling that once was things
start to fall apart when you stop caring
then i stopped caring a long time ago
how come you hate who you are
for some people it's too late to change
the damage they've done
he's hiding something
i want him dead
really
[Music]
the things you bury tend to haunt you
why did you disappear
hey old man
try this
you